je reçois maintenant celui qui a été
l'animateur star de la télévision des
années 2010 il était parti de rien pour
bâtir un empire télévisuel tout lui
réussissait
jusqu'au jour où il a commis l'erreur de
sa carrière celle qui l'a obligé à
quitter définitivement l'écran ça fait
maintenant dix ans que plus personne ne
l'a revu disant qu'on se demande ce
qu'il fait s'il est encore en vie s'il a
beaucoup grossi c'est notre invité t t
au cyril hanouna mesdames messieurs
l'homme qui avait fait de canal+ une
chaîne du groupe femu si la nina
alors
cyril valery isaac hanouna vous êtes né
le 23 septembre 1974 à paris dans une
famille tunisienne arrivée en france en
contrairement à tout ce qu'on a pensé
pendant des années vous n'êtes pas
d'origine pakistanaise
d'origine tunisienne vous avez bien
caché votre jeu si les bains vous dire
votre père anges à nouna et médecins
votre mère est gérant d'une boutique de
vêtements en france assez agitée vous
passionner pour le tennis beaucoup plus
que que pour vos études cyril je crois
qu'on peut le dire après le bac entamé
des études pour devenir expert comptable
comme laurent ruquier féret comme
laurent baffie trois mois est ce que est
ce que la comptabilité rang marrant
c'est très marrant les bilans quant aux
fleurs
avec l'âge j'ai pris la voie de navarro
c'est sûr que regarder dehors il a
toujours été drôlement quand il compte
une laurent baffie il va très vite parce
que je suis vraiment content et c'est un
facteur et moi pour rendre la monnaie
maintenant dans ma nouvelle activité sur
big man thor ça me ça va bien ben oui
bien sûr alors parallèlement fait
plusieurs petits boulots comme employé
de bandes vrp en tissu aussi mais à
cette époque déjà là la télévision fait
rêver non cyril j'adorais chameau ouais
ouais vous adoriez l'adoré je me mettais
tout nu sortez dans la rue
les gens étaient contents mais on se
rappelle d'ailleurs votre première
apparition c'était dans le juste prix
comme candidat on regarde
la vie et de la terre de tous les deux
oui tous les deux venus
vous aime faire longueur venait aussi
c'est olivier comment il s'appelle votre
copain c'est comment cyril bien sûr
venez sur une
je vous aime faire la même ambiance on
va faire des interviews de carlos et
vous faites la même ambiance que celle
que vous mettez dans le public
actuellement carlos bonjour l'élite vous
venez d'où carlos gervais n'dah vers
l'étang oui aux berbères les tons
berre-l'etang
[Applaudissements]
e
l'extérieur ça et vous a gagné quoi
cette semaine car l'eau j'ai gagné un
caméscope way
[Applaudissements]
up et plus des jumelles oui oui c'est
bien ça le met en forme et une selle de
cheval et
voilà alors
eux c'est le début de c1 1 à la
télévision extraordinaire passé c'était
il ya vingt kilos ce
ensuite vous avez participé au jeu que
le meilleur gagne comme candidat nagui
vous à d'ailleurs dit à l'époque que
vous alliez faire une carrière un ce
extraordinaire parce que maintenant ils
regrettent un peu finalement
non il regrette pas c'est vrai que
maintenant je le vois souvent on va
parler ma nouvelle activité chéri que
c'est une personne qui vient souvent me
voir mais je compte alors vous
apparaissez alors dans la grosse
émission vous êtes le stagiaire à
l'époque qu'on envoie à poil chercher
des trucs le supermarché franprix en
2003 vous remplacer michaël youn dans le
morning live de m6 vous restez pas très
longtemps sur m6 à trois voies payer
passé
là commence des années galères à cette
époque vivant encore chez vos parents
vous allez rester chez vos parents
jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans cyril entretien
non quand je suis parti ma mère est elle
a fermé la maison
et là vous rencontré votre femme oui
emilie à une époque vous n'avez pas
d'argent vous n'êtes pas connu
franchement c'est là faut le garder
ensuite ont présenté plusieurs émissions
à peu un peu sur toutes les chaînes mais
rien ne marche et en 2010 cyril vous
partez sur france 4 animer une émission
intitulée touche pas à mon poste et là
ça cartonne à la cartonne sur france 4
ont été de vrais qu'il ya devant france
ô ouais
l'une était les rois du monde les rois
de gamme
en mai 2012 lors du mercato vous signez
sur d8 début je croyais que c'était une
bataille navale
et là c'est un triomphe en quelques mois
touche pas à mon poste alias tpm paix
devient l'émission phare de la chaîne
vous devenez culte vos chroniqueurs
deviennent des stars les audiences
s'envole de ta votre top à ce moment là
c'est le top non vraiment le top et vous
êtes c'était le temps dans le top le top
le dada serait mon top le top la plupart
de vos émissions toutes les émissions
deux des huit c'est vous qui les fait
toyer léger toile tandis qu'à cette
époque il vous arrive et d'enregistrer
deux émissions différentes en même temps
faire sur deux axes caméra
et même les chroniqueurs république c
leurs voix là et à cette époque c'est
vrai que si on enlève cyril hanouna deux
des huit reste plus que la pub même pas
aimé dans les pubs et d'allemand on vous
a même demandé de participer d épisode
de navarro exactement que la chaîne
diffusait pour ça que je double iremam
encore jamais mais c'est sa voiture bar
le bistro l'anglais ça passait pas alors
justement tu fais pas mon poste atteint
les 20% de parts de marché contraignant
le grand journal as appelé le moyen
journal non c'est là que c'est à rien
non ça c'était déjà en 2015
alors j'ai décidé de parler d'autre
chose que de télé avec touche pas à mon
ballon pour parler de foot touche pas à
mon slip ouais c'est génial pour les
sexualités juge pas mon pognon pour
parler d'argent touche pas à mon
décolleté ça c'est une émission sur le
cancer du sein l'émission j'avais
vraiment nabila arrêts j'avais mis des
coups des couverts en plastique exact à
treize ans si
tout va bien pour nous je marche très
bien nous sommes le 15 septembre
2016 et là
c'est le drame
[Musique]
on
oui
le drame ou d'essayer de lancer une
nouvelle émission intitulée touche pas à
mon politique une émission censée
redonner aux gens l'envié de
s'intéresser à la politique firhill et
c'est là que vous invitez un soir
thierry solère
ça se passe pas bien on regarde
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de lancer une nouvelle
émission nous sommes à quelques semaines
de l'élection présidentielle bien sûr et
j'ai décidé de lancer cette nouvelle
émission touche pas à mon
merci pour cette première émission je
reçois thierry solère un peu doucement
oui
faire donc député des hauts-de-seine
bien si on pouvait réagir tout ce qu'il
va dire ce soir parce qu'il va parler à
la france il va parler aux français vous
pourrez agir dès maintenant sur hbo book
et sur twitter on va parler de tout ce
soir thierry bien sûr on va parler
chômage on va parler économie on va
parler bien sûr affaires étrangères on
va parler de tout ce qu'attendent les
français on va parler des problèmes des
français mais thierry la première
question que j'ai envie de vous poser ce
soir est-ce que sucer c'est tromper
vous aime beaucoup mais je suis venu sur
ce plateau pour parler politique moi je
suis député de la république un pardon
mais je crois que voilà je sais pas bien
compris moi j'ai rien à faire dans une
émission est un coup ça va
c'est vrai qu'ils rire quoi c'est vous
savez c'est important à la
représentation nationale les gens
croient en des choses il ya des députés
qui représentent les français et c'est
pas ma personne mais on s'est croisé
régulièrement moi oui aucun problème
avec vous mais vous m'avez expliquer
qu'on vous ait une émission politique
voilà moi je suis pas venu pour répondre
à ces corps
est-ce que s'il faut se tromper
[Applaudissements]
belle mentalité
immense scandale
alors que michel rocard m'avait répondu
avec amusement à cette question qu'ils
on fait référence à un bill clinton
là tout le monde vous vous tombe dessus
et tout le monde vous dit comment
peut-on poser une telle question à un
ministre c'est comme si vous je vous
pose est est-ce que sublet s'est trompé
ça a été très dur quand même à ce moment
là je croyais je me plais vraiment vous
allez morfler quoi je crois qu'on peut
le dire certains sympathisants tente de
lancer le mouvement touche pas mon
tunisien
ça a pris vous disparaissez du jour au
lendemain on ne voit plus cyril hanouna
les premiers tours vous faites comment
pour affronter les questions de ceux qui
vous disent eh bah alors qu'est ce que
tu deviens je vivote josée roig gc
j'essayais de revenir j'ai contacté le
recruter pour qu'ils me prennent dans
les grosses têtes
imagine tu n'as pas les compétences
moi j'y retourne sur europe 1 en face
ensuite j'ai contacté plein d'amis je
contacte arthur pour les enfants de la
télé m'a dit non tu as pas d'enfant
c'est ça mais c'est qu'à ce moment là
vous découvrez en fait que que les gens
que vous avez aimé vous avez invité tout
ça plus personne j'appris nagui est
alors j'aimerais prendre ta place m'a
dit votre programme
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous faisiez pendant
toutes ces années cyril au départ j'ai
je me soulier quelles sont mes forces
aujourd'hui ouais c'est vrai que j'ai
une force dit à ma force moi c'était mon
physique
cela dû être extrêmement difficile
très difficile heureusement qu'elle est
ma femme ouais elle m'a retrouvé comme
elle m'a fait connaître c'est vrai que
pendant un temps vous êtes parti vous
vous cachez au pakistan et il est dit là
bas personne de me reconnaître et
personne n'a reconnu s est prise alors
vous tenté à l'époque de vous
reconstruire et là c'est extraordinaire
avec vous une intuition vite pendant des
années les gens me confondait avec les
vendeurs de roses à un euro dans les
restaurants et vous dites c'est un signe
mon avenir est là et vous vous lancez
cyril hanouna dans la vente de roses and
go dans les restaurants parisiens ça a
été un carton tout de suite ça mais
j'étais collé en plus engagée des
vendeurs qui vous ressemble sa donc
comme les gens disent finalement c'est
peut-être cyril attias contactée plein
d'amis à sébastien folin qui a rejoint
la société
quand les gens croient que c'est vous
ils ont moins tendance à dire non et là
vous avez une autre idée une idée de
génie je crois qu'on peut le dire sur
chaque rose vous mettez en place une
garantie choper ou remboursé c'est à
dire que si l'homme qui achètent une
rose pour l'offrir à la fiq est en face
de lui n'a ri pak buchères lesquels vont
rembourser l'argent je rembourse la rose
randy des légumes en clair et coucher
quand même que chez hydro de la retraite
mais dieu soit loué les quais dans tous
les coeurs
pour acheter les magasins au nom de la
rose de dany vous rachetez monceau
fleurs et interflora c'est moi parce que
vous étiez le napoléon de la télévision
et vous devenez napoléon de la rose et
on regarde comment vous examine du paf
réagissent à votre descente aux enfers
et à votre subite reconversion
je ne peux que me souvenir de cirer les
noms parce qu'on a travaillé ensemble
j'avais une incroyable tendresse pour
lui il s'est pas rendu compte qu'il y
avait des limites à l'exercice et qu'on
pouvait pas tout faire avec avec des
politiques moi le premier je savais
qu'il allait dans le mur mais mais je
l'encouragé parce que je savais que
derrière ça me laissait à une autoroute
pour prendre sa place je suis
productrice et j'ai produit plein de
programmes sucer c'est tromper pour les
marseillais c'est la bonne question pour
un politique c'est impossible j'ai pas
compris parce que moi même je venais de
la politique et je sais que c'est pas du
tout le même exercice et puis surtout on
n'a pas du tout le même genre de clients
on peut pas aller aussi loin dans le
sourire dans la blague c'est au fond
c'est la france c'est au fond c'est la
mission de service public et de
responsabilité publique d'un homme
politique malgré tout ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher ça reste un excellent
producteur un accès en businessman il y
avait quand même réussi à vendre touche
pas à mes animaux à des huit qui était
quand même la plus grosse arnaque de la
télévision hélas aujourd'hui cartonne en
vendant des roses c'est là dessus il n'a
pas changé tant mieux pour lui puis
c'est ce qui pouvait arriver de mieux à
la télévision française et à moi
je dois dire qu'à chaque fois que je
passe devant un fleuriste je pense à lui
voilà
alors
s'il est ce que vous êtes nostalgie de
l'époque
touche pas à mon poste non plus du tout
maintenant mais vraiment nos souvenirs
dont les rosés tourner la page ben ouais
vraiment où j'ai perdu plein d'amis bien
entendu qui était avec moi autour de la
table weight ont passé l'armé à gauche
gérard voilà je t'embrasse fort jean
harlow
et si c'était à refaire qu'est ce que
vous feriez la même chose ah oui je vais
vous auriez la question à thierry solère
exact break away je suppose re matin
ouais ouais vraiment un peu prochain
j'arrive pas envie moi j'avais envie
d'arrêter au fond de moi ouais cyril le
jour vous allez mourir qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on écrive sur votre tombe
qu'est-ce qu'on essaierait au fond de
cette boîte
c'est la meilleure
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous êtes arrivé sur d8 comme
un pakistanais aujourd'hui vous êtes là
comme un qatari non
je me demande si je pars h et le plateau
des 1
alors ruquier hanouna sur le même
plateau
c'est pas une émission de télé mesdames
messieurs c'est yalta
faire une photo pour l'histoire on
appellera ça les accorde ya la
[Applaudissements]
guerre
mais à bouaké que moi
un joli décolleté il est venu conserver
alors en plus de la radio de la télé du
tennis vous chantez maintenant la compil
s'appelle touche pas à ma zik le premier
single s'appelle bob dabakh 2,9
featuring les frères bogdanoff salut des
extraterrestres
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir quelqu'un et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu